ladies and gentlemen we all know that
the American flag is indoor din its many
forms as the ultimate symbol of freedom
justice in the American Way but did you
know that our nation's flag was designed
by a high school student from Ohio
according to legend the original
American flag from 1776 was sewn by a
lady named Betsy Ross it had 13 stars in
a circle representing America's original
13 States as more states joined the
Union people kept adding more stars to
the flag
so by 1958 the US flag had a total of 48
stars for the 48 states of that time
which brings us to our high school
student Robert heft Roberts history
teacher gave his students and open-ended
assignment make a project illustrating
your interest in American history it
could be anything
so Robert who was jazzed about hearing
that Alaska and Hawaii were going to
become States cut up an old 48 state
flag in his grandparents basement and
designed his own vision for a 50 state
flag when he turned in his final
assignment Roberts teacher said anyone
can make a flag and it's got the wrong
number of stars the grade came back of B
- Robert tried to explain his idea to
his teacher who replied I'll change your
grade when your flag is accepted by the
US Congress game on Robert wrote 21
letters and called the White House 18
times until one day in 1960 Roberts
phone rang hello hello Robert it was
President Eisenhower with news that
Roberts 50-state flag design had
actually been chosen as the new official
flag of the United States the president
invited Robert to Washington where he
saw his American flag fly for the first
time on July 4th 1960
since then Roberts 50 state flag has
remained unmatched is the quintessential
symbol of America but I know what you're
thinking
whatever happened to that B - Roberts
teacher honored his promise and changed
the grade to an A
[Music]